wow welcome back to another episode of
the quarter of digital podcast thanks
for being here everybody it's episode
123.
joining us in his official son of a
dungeon uh costume and i got a sneak
peek
it's i'm
very surprisingly convinced that the
quality of that body suit you're wearing
i don't know what you're talking about
bodysuit
no we decided to take a page out of
disney and just like you know spend nine
months of physical training get to get
that doritos look dude i didn't know
that you were doing the full dorito look
you know maybe that doritos
maybe you should put sunscreen on so
that just ends right at your like
jawline
for like you know you want your body to
like work out
yeah
it looks like you've only been working
out in a cave for the last two years
did you see that
for uh people listening audio only ren
has an open chested uh costume on with a
very buff
um you know pecks and abs and uh it's
it's striking really let me feel that
coming here let's see the
it's pretty realism
it's pretty good but like the latex skin
feels pretty skin like it's squishy it
takes her silicone
silicone nipples the quality of the
silicone and
they're getting weird
okay it's surprisingly heavy too like
this bodysuit which cuts off at just
below my shoulders weighs like 10 or 15
pounds
it's a pretty heavy suit like you pick
it up and you're like wow that's a lot
heavier than i would have expected oh my
gosh we got waters incoming
cool
yeah i'm getting very hot in the suit so
that's a concern of mine is that like
i'm worried about overheating when it
comes time to actually shooting and
we're months away from shooting too i
don't know when we're gonna shoot but
the game itself the actual beginning
filming stages of son of a dungeon
a week from today
that's right
that's right get ready are you are you
guys ready nico are you ready
yeah i just sent sam my backstory by the
way uh part of it involves me and you
and i should send i should send it to
you also
yeah i think i'm gonna share backstories
this year with everybody because i
i was kind of like
hiding it last season thinking like oh
maybe this could reveal some vital
information that somehow will work
against the plot in the game but i
actually realized no
it would be better if everybody knew it
and that way they'd have context
and then you know like we can do more
character moments like we were talking
about today
which is something we want to do in
season two you know like sit people down
have a little bit more moments about the
development and the time that the
characters spend together so that when
they are in combat when they are you
know
in these
very dire situations
it's got more of that meaning you know
like you know them you've been there
with them
from the beginning
from the very beginning so i have also
submitted my backstory for both me and
chippy
oh and i can't tell you what that is
kind of i kind of wonder if you know
we're talking about all this backstory
be like great thanks for telling us that
your characters have backstory are you
like should we share a little bit of
backstory would that be around would it
be jumping the gun i'd be down a little
bit no i'm down i'm down i i i think
it's good i mean people will find this
out as they watch too and i don't think
it's um carmichael will be against this
but he's not here to stop us
so i'll start by just giving you the
little bit that i can all right
basically
there's more than meets the eye oh oh
what does that mean
what do you think that means jake we'll
see
transformers more than meets the uh
that's the eye yeah yeah yeah
uh i'm gonna yes no you're right nico
i'm gonna turn into a truck just like
clint always dreams
i don't even know sam's roommate anymore
all right so
so my character is a druid and he comes
from a a tribe out in the woods of about
60 people
and uh you know it's all very nature
based um
you know they they worship nature as
their god trees are their jesus if you
will and uh
and there's a traumatic event in my
character's past about ten years ago
where
uh nest's brother uh got gored by a boar
and scored by more gourd by a boar
don't make jokes about nest's brother
died i'm sorry
sorry
the whole druidic circle and the elders
in the village were out in a vision
quest so
i grabbed his brother and they headed
into the nearest town to see if they
could find a doctor there to heal you
know to help him up but they didn't have
any money because they're just a tribe
out in the woods you know they've never
like partaken with modern society and
the doctor wouldn't take him in and his
brother died so he lost his brother at
that point he vowed that at that point
he would he would never let he not let
this tribe get uh left behind as
civilization moved on and he was going
to become the bridge to modern society
that's so noble yeah so you're going to
say that he like vowed that he'd never
not have money again
he always had money well pretty much so
he's like i'm going to get
he found himself basically as this
unique link where he's effectively the
ambassador between the the border of the
wilderness and of civilization you know
he's helping solve problems as uh as man
runs into
beast
and uh and in that process you know he's
this naive druid that comes from the
woods you know he meets this bard this
partying bard named warren and warren is
basically his tour guide to all luxuries
and modern amenities of modern society
which turns out nest loves he loves
drinking he loves sports he especially
loves gambling um
i'm so excited for this took a u-turn i
thought this was gonna be a wholesome
word
if you watch closely in season one we
tried to do some gambling but it was
always shot down i think we got to do it
this season yep
yeah we're always trying to bet on
things because the thing is like
you know ness sends whatever money you
can back to his tribe which is like
not most of it because most of it
actually gets spent gambling
scaling addiction but the tribe
they learned like how lawless he had
become like he's here like look you can
go to the land of no trees
just because you know you're doing this
for the betterment of the tribe and if
they knew
that how much money he was blowing on
gambling versus sending back to the
tribe like you're done you're out of the
druid circle
things might get ugly for nest
but i don't at this point ness is pretty
powerful
that's true yeah dude the whole freaking
microwave
ending yeah
dude
the double microwave oh so on that note
uh
so when we were doing the solo world
video last year matt and i
both it became a bit of a meme between
the two of us every time we'd like turn
on a light instead of saying strike him
would be like
moon beam
we just we said moon beam so many times
throughout the course of that project
we'd be like sitting down so like all
right now we're gonna do this shot and
uh moon beam in the next shot
that's so stupid
and uh when alex barbatus was working
with us um he's an old friend of ours
and uh he was really into wwe wrestling
and there was a there's a
character in wwe wrestling called rafiki
and rafiki's move was to back that ass
up onto people's faces
and it was called the stink face he
would like suffocate people with his
butt
and um
yeah
so
that it became a production phrase any
time something just needed a little bit
extra you just put a little ass on it
because he had that song that he's
saying well actually i don't know if
that was
yeah and so like the light was too damn
like you know like you put a little ass
on it yeah yeah yeah just put a little
ass on it you'll be fine
the performance is good but then for
this next one just put a little ass on
it
oh it was rikishi
rafiki's from the lion king
like there's someone from wwe named
after a monkey from
baboon though with one of those big
butts you know so i mean that kind of
works
he's also a real-life cousin of dwayne
the rock johnson uh part of the famous
wrestling uh i know
i'm pronouncing this wrong but and no uh
ie family
um yeah there's a bunch of famous
wrestlers in that family huh crazy
dynasty
yeah it really is
anyways um
so the woods
so there's the woods well long story
short you know nest filling with warren
like ness had this skill that he
realized that he could uh help them deal
with the frontier
and warren had all the connections to
like the governorship and the nobility
and he's like there's all these like
open contracts that like we could take
care of and so we went out there and
started taking care of it we started
making a lot of money and then we
discovered sports gambling
and sports betting on the season i mean
you always bet on the crushers right
uh winner bet against the christmas
sports
yep
and uh so that's really uh what nest's
life was like currently uh you know
trying to kind of keep this all a bit of
a secret from the tribe like oh it's so
tough i'm just grinding it out here's
all the money i made
in reality that's not exactly the case
but uh yeah that's that's a little bit
of a backstory as to uh why he's doing
what he's doing and how he got linked up
with warren
and and ran you can't how much can you
reveal
ren uh
i mean
my back story
isn't that important for just general
sort of knowledge of the crew and or the
tribe or what are we calling ourselves
the
the party yeah that's that's the term
the party the band the band of merry
compatriots yeah that's right
and
yeah uh we're just uh expanding upon the
back story with me and chippy how we
came to be chippy's family etc chippy's
backstory
and i'm excited for it it's gonna have
big implications for the the main story
i'm pretty sure
because it's like
sam and i came up with this idea to kind
of like
twist that a little bit in a really
interesting way
and i think sam's just gonna sit on that
so i think that's gonna become a big
story element of the actual season
i don't know how yet
i'm just saying
okay
well
um
i'm excited to find out
i i'm excited to see what chippy's
backstory is because most of the time
you know for squirrels
it's pretty simple
sorry sorry for chipmunks it's pretty
simple
just comment come and go you know eat a
nut you know
that's pretty much nuts
yeah
uh all right so um warren uh
you know nico's kind of hinted at some
of some of my my history but um
i'll just read to you a little story
about warren now as you guys know if
you've seen season one uh we're going to
the underdark and that's about all we
know as well as players um so don't
worry uh this is all context and no
spoilers um so after his parents were
tragically killed at the exact same time
by being hit with a speeding sports ball
during a performance at a cecilton
crushers game warren spent his
adolescence being raised by his barred
uncle luther watt
his mother was a human and his father
and uncle were wood elf brothers he was
raised in an elven community outside of
cecilton where his father and uncle's
family came from a long line of high
bards the bars would often be employed
on diplomatic missions by nobles and
other high societies to
trade things between the underdark and
the world above places that nobles
themselves did not want to go but wanted
things to go and things to come from
some of warren's most influential
experiences came from the times he spent
with luther in the underdark and because
of this his favorite terrain is caverns
oh in what in one underdark adventure at
the age of 15
deep in a drow city warren was separated
from his uncle when he was shot with a
poisonous arrow and kidnapped by drows
he was held as ransom in exchange for a
book of ruin that his uncle's party was
attempting to transport but when the
drows attempted to trap and kill luther
and his party warren stole the book of
rune and used it to invoke intense
sunlight which injured the enemy drows
and saved all but one of the adventuring
party
little tophas's grandfather oh who
sacrificed himself in a heroic act
involving lots of acid and a lumen's
tiny
in another adventure at the age of 26
warren and lutheran discovered that a
noble house of drows were the ones who
actually planned the attack that killed
warren's parents as it turns out the
plot was a wicked attempt by the house
to seek revenge on their distant kin of
the what line of wood elf who had played
a critical role in their original
banishment from the under to the
underdark oh wow as a result warren and
luther formed a war party to enter a
drow city and slaughter an entire line
of noble drow with the help of a larger
war chest financed by luther and
warren's friends in high places in the
world above and some below dozens were
killed some say hundreds
as a result of this much favor from the
other houses of drow or was won and
helped establish a highly profitable but
incredibly dangerous trade economy with
the other drows and noble houses above
despite the danger warren and luther
paid off their war debt and more which
is how warren was able to establish
himself as a respectable citizen of
cecilton
however some years went by and rumors
still has it that warren and luther did
not finish off every one of their
distant kin
something warren has grown more and more
suspicious of since the mysterious
disappearance of his uncle about a year
ago that had evidence of drow at play
but maybe it was just all that sketchy
trading nobody knows for sure
damn
wow what a back story yeah that was that
was in depth
meanwhile i'm over here being like
there's more than meets the eye
did you feel the adventure are you guys
ready yeah
my whole day today was all about just
trying to get into the mindset of
bob
you throw rocks around i throw boulders
around that's cool rocks
cool
i like that
method acting yeah
what makes a high barred high
like how are you born higher do you get
high
a little bit of both okay
so is is warren high or is he normal
uh well he's pretty high now he's on his
way gotcha so you're just on a mission
to get high
yeah yeah pretty much as any bard yeah
it's a byproduct
some people say that they're op in the
dnd universe because they can sort of
serve so many different functions and
roles but
um a high bar would just be somebody
who's
you know
like
at the highest levels of like
you know playing oh levels
gotcha yeah right yeah
right a little bit too much huh he's
been high but he's not
yeah thanks for that clarification cool
so we got i always heard like imagine a
high bar is like they play at nobility
parties oh okay
like a tavern yeah okay sure that makes
sense right the beethovens of the
exactly exactly it's like they become
though like you know historical orders
of the uh
of the area yeah bards serve an
important function to you know
transfer human culture from one
generation to the next
yep
and in the game they're basically your
non-combat fighter like when you do a
fight
a battle of the minds
or of the wits or of the
musical fingers that is the bard's job
right yep we we do everything butt fight
pretty much yep
try to avoid it at all costs unless we
form a war party in which case all bets
are off roses are red violets are blue
and today's sponsor manscaped is here
for you with their performance package
4.0 just in time for valentine's day
that's right it's got everything you
need it's got the good smells it's got
the good look you got the whole thing
going on and you're out on the day for
valentine's day and where you had a
sushi restaurant i'm sure it's delicious
but you know what with this performance
package from manscape you're going to be
even more delicious let me tell you why
because the first thing that it offers
is the lawnmower 4.0 the fourth
generation of their signature trimmer
it's got a 4000k led light so you can
see in those hard to reach places and it
has the patented skin safe technology
signature on all the manscape trimmers
and that's going to allow you to be less
likely to clip and cut yourself while
you're doing what you got to do in
addition to the lawnmower it's also got
the weed whacker what is the weed
whacker it is the ultimate nose and ear
trimmer just for you this thing has 9
000 rpm motor powered 360 degree rotary
dual blades
the hair is just gone oh and guess what
it's waterproof you can use it in the
shower pretty good manscaped good job
guys but that's not all they're throwing
in the performance package they're also
throwing in their shed travel bag and
their anti-chafing boxer briefs now i
have pair of these boxes myself
absolutely love them i wear them all the
time i mean not every day obviously i
wash them but i wear them when they're
clean they're my go-to's and they're
very comfortable so that's what's going
on in their performance package 4.0 it's
a perfect thing just in time for
valentine's day if you guys are
interested in getting some for yourself
head on over to manscape.com and use the
code corridor cast and you'll get 20 off
plus free shipping that's manscaped.com
with the promo code corridor cast for 20
off plus free shipping now back to the
podcast
we've gotta do a brand deal with
lehman's tiny hut
but the company is for real rei to
sponsor it or something
all right
[Laughter]
is literally just like a big bubble
shield it's a force field gotcha they
didn't call it forcefield they call it
lehman's tiny hut
right for some reason they didn't call
it a force field yeah because it's also
a lehman's like large hut also
oh lemons has a few products actually
that's what i'm saying is uh lehman
secret
he's got it all
oh man i'm just saying you know lehman's
we could have a lot of cross promotion
here
promoting there oh i should get it i
should get a chest
so the secret chest you can hide a chest
and all of its contents on the ethereal
plane
you must touch the chest and the
miniature replica that serves as a
material component for the chest
um and uh and that's how you do it but
the chest remains i think in the
ethereal plane if you die
do you think there's just like a million
chests up there from all the way
probably there's a bunch of hits
throughout time
that's where the treasure's at
you can hold rare material constructed
from rare materials worth at least 5 000
gold pieces wow that's an expensive
chest
oh only wizards can have this okay
okay it's a good thing what if i had one
that was enchanted by a wizard yeah i
mean
and then i had a little whistle that i
could call to the wizard and then he
would
you know yeah or it's just
you know enchanted chest item
yeah don't let your dreams be dreams
jake do it
don't let them live in the ethereal
plane yeah
are you coming in material are you
flying in over the weekend
i'm finding monday morning oh wow okay
waking up at 1 45 a.m pacific time
oh
i'm gonna fly my butt out to southern
california i will likely still be awake
[Laughter]
i will text you if you're awake
and i'll tell you to go to sleep
good just text ren o-m-w
[Laughter]
be right there
p-r-t
[Laughter]
brt
just so using acronyms that like
whatever they stand for
oh man i i just learned that gnarly you
know the word gnarly gnar like shred the
gnar nar is an acronym oh really i just
learned this
but don't tell us what it is let's guess
it go with not
all right g-g-n-a-r
right
13th century
oh you're never going to guess it you're
never going to guess let me try to try
let me try risk it radical
risk at all
go nuts here we go
go nuts and crash
no it's it's an arm
knack
go nuts and rip
that's that's close that's that's what's
interesting it's not i mean it's not
close but i like it go nutso and rip no
it's the first word is a name
gary's gary's never
around
gaffney's
gaffney's yeah like lehman's tiny hut
yeah
stands for
gaffney's numerical assessment of
radness oh wow i'm not kidding this is
this is an actual thing that's right and
no one knows about it yeah shred the
gnar
you're off the charts
oh my god yeah they wanted to come up
with a way to like measure points of
like who's doing the most gnarly stuff
see i'm saying it right now like i'm
literally using a terminate coin
to describe the term that they coined
sorry because it's like an acronym
people always think of acronyms as just
being an abbreviation of the first
letters of words right but an acronym is
actually only
when those
letters form a new word like nasa nasa
is an acronym but what is a kickflip in
our points
like
five
so yeah i don't know hey speaking of
gnar points uh you guys do something
pretty gnarly oh dude are we gonna talk
about that yeah let's talk about it okay
so you tell me are we gonna talk about
it oh yeah yeah we can talk about it
i think but i'm going to anyway
so over the weekend after that i'm going
to talk about a list of lesser know
lesser known acronyms
perfect
acronyms of lesser being lesser power
so over the weekend my friends
over at this small company called future
motion came down for the weekend
uh they make this product called the one
wheel oh yeah just fyi yeah so they were
in town
uh we hung out for a day
the end
that's all you can say come on brah no
okay so i got to try the new one-wheel
gt
and it is
off the charts of the gaffney's
uh
[Laughter]
i mean is that what gt stands for is it
like daphne's
uh thunder or
japanese
[Laughter]
technically apparently according to kyle
uh who invented the onewheel xr on the
onewheel xr stands for extra rad
oh really oh so
it is coming back okay extra bad
radness
we got an xr
nice gasket
radness
[Laughter]
so yeah i gotta try the new onewheel gt
now they are still in pre-production of
all of their units there there is a
delay currently there's uh i i don't
know which components they're short on
but everything else is ready to go and
as soon as they get those components
they'll start shipping them out mr
there's a delay
so yeah i gotta try either one of two
engineering units that exist in
in reality
and i didn't get to write it very much i
went up and down the street a few times
i i toiled around a little bit in like
an intersection and that was pretty much
the extent of my experience riding the
new onewheel but
i have some thoughts first thought it is
awesome it is legit powerful and and so
i was
not quite racing but i was going fast
and my friend who was on the xr he was
getting surging and he wasn't able to
keep up as easily because on a one wheel
you can just go until it gives out
and i didn't push it that far but i did
push it to the point where i hit
pushback
and push back is just the mechanism the
onewheel employs to
inform you that you're hitting the
limits of what the onewheel can do and
how it activates is it literally like
pushes back on you it tilts backwards
because the one way back is actually an
acronym
that's the one pause under strenuous
bored
and okay sorry i'm done yeah i mean
because it's like people are like oh why
don't you just put like why didn't they
just put brakes on the one wheel and i
was like that's not how one wheels work
that's called a nose dive yeah it breaks
on you because you can't just like slow
it down there's that's the physics
involved don't allow for that so you
have to like inform the writer that
they're at the limits of the one wheel
rather than taking over and stopping
them so what they've chosen to do is to
basically change the orientation of the
one wheel to be
tailed down and that's called push back
and it can be kind of jarring sometimes
it's pretty jarring on the pint and the
pushback on the gt is
pretty similar i will say that it is it
starts pretty rapidly but i will say the
the pushback on the gt starts pretty
late
uh like it doesn't start at a lower
speed you have to really hit like 20
miles an hour for the pushback to really
activate again i have very limited
experience with it so take my words with
the regular one
xr it's like 15 miles an hour 60 miles
an hour you'll start to feel that lean
yeah you're getting to the ends of what
we can do to keep up with you but then
you can push through that and it'll go
back to normal and now you're writing at
the literal
like extent of what the motor can do and
so it's very easy to push it too far and
you can nose dive and break your
collarbone uh
some of us here have experience with
that not me obviously yeah
anyway so the not with abs like those
not with absolutely musculature like
that you know
not with pauldrons like those my family
you should wear those when you ride that
might save your collarbone next time
dude yeah
right
if you were football if you wore
football armor though you'd be you'd be
good to go and you'd look cool too yeah
yeah style points would make up for all
of it
yeah
so uh one of the things i was most
curious about with the gt was the weight
and it is heavier but my onewheel which
is pretty much as souped up as it could
possibly be
isn't that much lighter i think my
onewheel is somewhere around like 33 34
pounds and the gt is 35 pounds and so
it doesn't feel notice like it's
noticeably heavier but not in a
noticeably bad way like i'm able to pick
it up just fine and didn't
i was able to write it i was able to do
uh an s-spin i'm pretty sure i'm the
first person to do an s-spin on a
one-wheel gt which is the type of trick
early
that's at least a
seven on the target
but i did a bunch of like curb climbs on
it and it handles curb climbing so well
it's just got so much power ready to go
and yeah it's like they're still
limiting you to 20 miles an hour on
speed before like push back kind of
really starts trying to slow you down
but everything up until that point just
feels so much safer than a one-wheel xr
and and so i felt very secure on it even
just a little bit of riding that i did
and there was this one steep area that
we went where uh the i was up on a
sidewalk it was a pretty steep spot and
i'm confident that an xr wouldn't have
been able to go over this bump
it wasn't a bump it was just like a ramp
right and the gt just went right up just
like
like no problem
yeah also what's cool and crazy is that
like if you if you kind of do a half
jump and like
lift your back foot
uh that's kind of like the base of
like kicking out rocks or bonking over
things to get some air if you do that on
flat ground
just that lack of friction is enough to
make the tire spin out and then half a
second later when your weight lands back
on the foot pad
uh it skirts like skirt
so like i could literally make the
onewheel gt skirt on command just like
skirt you wanna do some burnouts cause i
could do it on the xr but i have to hit
a bit of a bump i have to hit a bump to
get enough air so that the wheel can
spin up and then hit the ground skirt
dude gt just got more torque a lot more
towards this one's got a lot more
tearing up the neighborhood dude yeah
we've been skid marks everywhere little
tiny skid marks
oh the studio floor in a few months
so uh yeah and and
i didn't try an actual like donut
burnout so uh my friend did one and it
worked it works yeah it does it but
i i tried i
one of the tricks i did and i did it on
camera i'm not allowed to share any of
the photos and videos that i took yet
it's kind of under embargo
uh this video i got i i managed to do a
sex change where i basically jump up
turn my body 180 degrees land back on
the one wheel i could do that fine on
the regular one wheel but i
the gt is slightly top heavy and so when
i did that spin it rolled over onto its
side and i landed on the the rails primo
like when you land on the side really
cool trick it's a pretty sweet trick and
i was like whoa but then my then it
rolled back and my legs kicked out and i
landed flat on my back and i hit my
elbow really hard so i don't know if you
see the bruising on my elbow
here
yeah
but my elbow hurts
that's just part of your default skin
yeah so it's uh
i am apparently not the first person to
draw blood off of a one-wheel gt
but again they've literally only got two
units and they were hand built
and and so you did so you did a trick
trick ever and you were the first not
the first to bleed on it yeah
okay but no it was cool because they
were in town doing some photo shoots
they're still like doing promotional
stuff for it they're not actually
launching it yet and since i'm friends
with the guys they just text me like hey
you around i was like yeah i'm around do
you know how many they sold
how many onewheel gts they pre-ordered
yes i don't know
at least
100.
honestly i wouldn't be surprised if they
managed to get several thousand
there's uh
only several thousand i would expected
much more of of one-world gt pre-orders
i mean maybe i don't know
i do know that there's approximately 250
to 300 000 onewheels in the wild
and i don't know that from future motion
the number might be higher that's just
what i've been able to get from
uh estimations from various people who
sell one wheel accessories
you know like the onewheel is pretty
like
it was a pretty like life-changing
device i think for a lot of us but like
absolutely it's what got me out into
nature a lot more that's the biggest
thing yeah absolutely you know climbing
to the top is like because ellie's
surrounded by nature there's nature in
the middle of la but it's in mountain
form and mountains are not the most kind
thing to people's legs
no and it's like it's
you know hikes are great getting up out
into nature is great everyone enjoys
that for the most part but if you're
sitting on the couch thinking what to do
with the next five hours of your life
and you don't really have the energy to
go out and do an activity
the idea of going on a hike
you might not reach that critical
threshold of actually doing it yeah and
so what ends up happening for most
people is that they just never get out
into nature but the one wheel takes that
threshold of activation energy
requirements why am i getting technical
without phrasing anyway
it makes it so easy just to get out in
the nature like you're saying and so the
mere fact that i can be like yeah i feel
like being on top of a mountain and
literally one hour from right now i can
be on top of a mountain if i wanted to
yeah maybe an hour and a half to commute
to the base of the mountain and then one
roll up but you know what i mean i think
you just came up with another acronym a
rare
ren's activation energy requirement
yeah dude that was hella rare dude
there's a large there's large but to the
whole getting to the top of the mountain
thing which is a the one with xrs kind
of run out of batteries oh yeah because
the bottoms are so big here and then two
you're still climbing a mountain and
unless the road is somewhat smooth
you can't get to the top of the mountain
necessarily you know yeah like they're
actually they're pretty dang good and
the fact that onewheel xrs are so good
that like
yeah you can use the top mount as long
as take a fire road but it's also just
like
you see what it could be it's like wow
what if i could do this anywhere and
people are like they're always surprised
like wait you ride that up this mountain
every time i'm right back down it's like
now i can show up with the gt and like
oh i ride this everywhere
you know yeah anywhere i mean that's
been my that was my home like when they
announced it's like i hope this truly
lets me
shred off the side of a mountain in the
way that the xr can't
i think it's going to be yeah i'm very
much so looking forward to taking it
i write this on everything
i write in the ocean
[Laughter]
and another big thing that i obviously
wasn't able to test at all was the range
of the onewheel gt which is supposed to
be around 30 miles
30 miles of range on the one wheel gt
drool now granted that's really 20 to 30
miles of range depending on how you ride
if you're going up a mountain you're
looking at probably seven miles in range
yeah which is still pretty cool that's a
lot of miles down it is no it's straight
up it
with that is dude yeah yeah you're gonna
have to yeah so but if you're just going
like at a medium speed on flat ground in
the middle of kansas you'll probably be
able to easily get 30 miles yeah
yeah i'm really excited it's
la holds so much nature it's just it is
it can only be unlocked with electric
vehicles or somebody who has a lot of
time and really strong legs and
endurance yeah
yeah and like we can go up to the
mountain at the end of the day too
because if you go on a hike it's like oh
let's get up early and get our energy
out you know yeah but we go at the end
of the day and then we just
it's amazing most of the rides we go on
we meet up at like 9 00 9 30 p.m and
then we go up to the top of the mountain
and pitch black nice and cool
there's no one else on the mountain so
we have it to ourselves there's like a
nice
private feeling about it being up there
and knowing that there's literally no
one else around you because i remember
back in the very early days being like
oh man it might be kind of sketchy going
up on top of the mountain in the middle
of the night it might be like bears it
is a little sketchy by yourself yeah and
there might be large drops that you can
have your one wheel fall down nico
hey you did it too all right
or you yourself can fall down them did
you tell that story yet am i wheel dying
dude not yet
there's a there's a ride that we do
called the steakhouse because we've
always said the stakes are high yeah but
we finally had a real casualty on the
steakhouse it finally like paid for its
namesake yep and this was like the
fourth or fifth time aboard fifth or
sixth time aboard had actually tumbled
down the mountain but this was the first
time the mountain claimed a life yeah my
board's life yeah my board we ren tried
very hard he for two days straight like
a doctor he worked on it taking it apart
and putting it back together and trying
different things he was not able to
bring it back to life so i think
something's wrong with the battery
management system
and yeah yeah which is crazy because
nat's board fell like three times as far
but it was fine and it was out there all
night long my mind's actually falling
off this i mean mine fell off twice that
night
i was like being pretty lackadaisical
with it like it's falling off the
steakhouse edge like about four or five
times now
um you were like never too seriously but
that night i was just like whatever i'm
sending it
um you know maybe is the knowledge of
the gt's in the horizon maybe it was
just you know protecting fate
i don't know what it was but uh either
way
doesn't work
yep so i ivy has a one wheel
and i'm thinking
about taking it apart and using the
pieces to make my onewheel work which is
the way to go you've got the upgraded
battery yeah
you have the cbxr battery which is like
a off-market upgrade that yep try
battery systems which doesn't work with
all one wheels too by the way it's like
it only works with the older one wheels
yeah that still have the open connection
between the controller and the battery
management system
ever since like
halfway through the xr production range
they actually started connecting the two
so if your controller dies you can't
just get a new controller you have to
get a new controller and a new battery
which makes it like prohibitively
expensive to just replace components
which is really unfortunate i really
don't like that decision from future
motion to to do that it really kind of
cuts down on
stuff like this for yeah anyway
point being is that ivy's board is old
enough that you can just take the bms
from her board and put it in your board
assuming that that's the problem i have
i thought i eliminated the bms as the
problem twice already and
i have also now eliminated every other
component on the board being the problem
so it has to be this yeah well you're
gonna be speaking in acronyms again so
wouldn't you rather have a gt and a cbx
our board i would i would i would
but here's the thing
it's ivy's board
but you can say hey ivy i'll give you my
my cbxr xr
you know
half of half of everything that's yours
is yours bro exactly that's right you
hear the front half with the controller
in it i don't need that i'm gonna take
the back
there you go you're good to go
all right all right you guys interested
in some lesser-known acronyms
yeah am i ever
all right
nick the enthusiasm try to keep it down
man
sorry keep it down i just love the
acronyms here's the first one
laser
oh yes i knew this one light
no something radiating
it's got light and it's got radiation
zapper
i forget i used to know this one but i
forget it starts with lightning and
light radiation
something
i don't know
guys i'm reading this from
bbc.co.uk this is a one of those
articles that they think people are
going to land on when they're bored at
work so don't
hate me if i get this all wrong but
here's what they have to say about the
laser okay everyone loves a good ra a
good laser i mean particularly in the
context of a james bond film a
um wow
it's kind of funny after all who could
ever forget the famous laser crotch nail
biting moment in goldfinger we sure
didn't
um but anyways
here's what it means
chop them in half sorry
light amplification by simulated
emission of radiation
simulated or stimulated stimulated
emission of radiation you're right
we're not simulating some radiation what
is this a stimulated emission of
radiation
also it should be pronounced labsur
[Music]
only when you say it really slow do you
say the b
did you ever have one of them labs or
pointers growing up
man kids these days and all their labs
are swords and chopping them down what
else is another saber scuba
scuba i knew that yeah
i don't know what that stands for but i
didn't know that was not contained
underwater breathing apparatus dang how
did you hear that nailed it i read books
excuse me
i read a book that said that
chapter one
michael nailed it
um all right here's another one taser
um
tactical
assisted um
something is it the same as laser
because then s or z i always want to get
a z for these words s zapper
can you spell it
tactical snapper that's the t the t-a-z
[Laughter]
it has a spell
s swelled with an s
the name of the company it's not the
actual device
i don't know if it's the name of the
actual company but apparently uh
there was an acronym
sorry the word stands for thomas a swift
electrical rifle
after the inventor jack cover decided in
1974 to name it after his fair favorite
children's book character tom swift
don't you know
so awesome yeah
okay which is weird though because
to describe it as an electric rifle is
almost wholly inaccurate because there's
nothing rifled about it
but okay
uh all right here's some more
spam
um
god spiced ham
yes wow nice that's an abbreviation you
son of a [ __ ]
oh okay
there's two possible no one knows for
sure
one is special processed american meat
oh my god that sounds like the worst
that's what it
is well it was invented
sorry it was became popular during world
war ii and there's two other famous
world war two acronyms
that fubar
yes fubar and
snafu oh yeah
you s you know i i just recently we
watched the quarter crew episode about
boss town 2 and how he lost all the
footage and you
said this in the video
it was like situation nominal
all f'ed up
situation normal all left up
nominal normal phenomenal yeah
yeah um so we got those going for us
guys those are the acronyms of the
day i hope i got i mean i can get more
of i hope gaffney's proud of it
we gotta play boulder dash because we
could we could make up our own acronyms
and then have to guess the real one i'm
just saying we could make up
our own acronyms or
[Music]
oh speaking of that's what that means
aot
uh
wow that was i just said stuff that i
was i was having a conversation in my
head i just realized
sorry i was thinking of some acronym i
was like a-o t-t oh yeah aot attack on
titan
speaking of afd it's like mello hasn't
said those words
are you all right i haven't seen the new
episodes yet i'm looking forward
oh man i can't believe the second one
ended like that it was such a
cliffhanger
oh i'm dripping in tonight okay i can't
wait
and now because of it i'm like i'm
getting hyped again i'm like man i want
to make another i want to make another
attack on titan scale video do it
do it because but it's like by necessity
there's going to have to be a little bit
of like spoilery stuff like
yup
i don't know i've read the manga so i
know what happens and so i already am
planning on what i could do
and there there's some bigger titans
there's also going to be
i'm not going to say anything else i'm
not going to say anything else
perfect hey ren do you know what ted
talk means
no it's not the education there's a guy
named ted
okay
[Laughter]
tell me explain to me describe to me
oh apparently apparently according to
abbreviations.yourdictionary.com
of course
that's really redundant
yeah it it really is
[Laughter]
tell me describe
can you tell me and explain to me nasdaq
north american
digital
and
i learned this in like econ class about
10 years ago i don't know yeah
national association of securities
dealers automated quotation oh those
tricksters
quotation
i guess yeah
that's what they done that's what they
done did tell me okay are you really
starting to hit the bottom of the barrel
with these acronyms here i know i think
hey they got fubar on here though so we
got that going
yeah that's it none of these are good
none of these are gnarly with gnarly
yeah i i was just i was literally blown
away when i learned i i think i saw her
on a tick tock or something like that
some guy was like yeah so actually like
gnarly comes from
gaffney's
uh
was a graphical assessment of radness i
just really hope that was his first name
assessment of radness hell yeah do you
think he's really stingy you're like you
do a cool trick like
[Music]
point three
and you're like no
the scale only goes up to two
that's negative one
[Laughter]
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute ren
your theory
there's a science fiction book from 1939
called the gnarly
that's what i always thought the word
stood for was just like like rocky yeah
like when lumberjacks go to get some
timber they don't want to cut into the
gnarly stuff because it's going to be
hard to fill the tree you're like let's
go fully let's go fully uh like
etymology
okay all right according to etymology
sources
this word gnarled dates back to the
1600s probably a variant of the middle
english
knurled or gnar which is of course where
we get knob or not
uh
you know
i don't know maybe that guy was making
it up man i think he got us all
full of crap he's full of [ __ ] yeah
google gasps
numerical oh that's right here
autocomplete
gaffney's miracle assessment of radness
or nar sorry g dot n dot a dot r is a
game invented by skiers shane mcconkey
and rob gaffney determine who is the
raddest skier on the mountain take the
test to find out how red you actually
are
wait can we take the test wait this is
basically just another
facebook test wait i want to take it oh
no all right we'll take the test let's
see how rad we are all right guys
i get through all these ads
oh
first question have you ever skied naked
not now no
no
i have one wheeled naked
have you ever got first lifts on a
powder day
yes actually i have yes first
have you ever shouted i'm the best skier
on the mountain yes
no i'm not dean yes
[Music]
you have you ever told a pro writer
instructor that you are completely
better than them
damn no you just kind of like [ __ ]
questions
like you shove their way in the first
little line and they're like you are
better than you
[Music]
i'm the best
[Laughter]
all right at the start of a run have you
ever shouted hey look at me i'm going to
nail this i am amazing
what
no
no dude
oh my god this guy sounds like a total
a-hole this was the bullet guy in all
the 80s ski movies
for another point but there's only 10
points here all right we're on point
number six
have you ever farted on a ski lift and
claimed it
like no one can smell it
oh you don't want your butt to be cold
all right ready number seven
have you ever lost anything on the
mountain
that's what they mean
yes
oh that kind of looked good i see
all right have you ever answered yes are
you ever cutting two lift cues
dude i guess was this rude
it should be like there should be a you
lose a point if say yes on that one
have you ever injured yourself on the
slopes and had to go home
[Laughter]
have you ever called your mom
no you're kidding me
yeah have you ever called your mom while
hooting down the mountain
[Laughter]
i was spot-on
how do you spell that
h-o-o-n-i-n-g look it up hooning
crunch
another economy a car what is it
nick actually managed to call that like
he was just making fun of this test and
then the test just played into your
cards oh hooning is like an australian
slang word uh okay uh hooting is a
common word used for any anti-social
behavior in a motor vehicle such as
speeding street racing burnouts loud
music car stereo
so driving a car down the mountain have
you ever called your mother
i put them out yes yes
went down the mountain all right i have
our gnar score
didn't give me a dang number it just
gave me a judgment
you are the
least raddest person we know
by that judgment that is a high
compliment
sorry dude you're about as rad as near
entry ski boots you can become radder by
becoming a skier snowboard instructor
take a look at our courses to see what
you've got oh come on guys you're trying
to sell me snowboard courses
gaffney is rolling in his grave right
now nico dude i give that a nice score
of negative a million
negative 10 on than our score
oh my god wow
i couldn't believe that
i feel like gaffney is like dean's
grandfather or something dude
gaffney's a mean man but yeah
put that on the record assuming he did
all the things that were in those
questions he sounds like a total dick
just pushing himself to the front of the
line yeah he has to be first i'm a
better skier than anybody here
hey mom guess what
i i lost something
this does not sound fun oh my gosh
that's how you measure radicalness or
radness i guess
i'm naked on the skin
i think we've misappropriated this term
i think nar's an insult guys oh my
goodness gnarly is not a good thing oh
man i'm not going to use it anymore
guys guys i think it gets worse hold on
oh no
um i'm seeing here okay maybe this isn't
real
uh
what could jacob possibly hold up that
he's making us
[Laughter]
it's a movie poster for nara the movie
okay
and apparently it came out in 2011.
and it's actually from what i can tell
it
involves scott gaffney and rob gaffney
and shane mccockley
the original nar guys you're a kid
no
is it a ski film or is it like like a
narrative no
what is this is it is this a drawing or
is this real
gnar the mood to watch this
research
all right i'm gonna pull this up too
gnar
is a movie it is a movie directed by rob
gaffney and scott
he's a star
starring shane mcconk
mcconkey
scott gaffney and rob gaffney
wow
looks like a national lampoon kind of
thing
i don't know if you can see this up on
this on the camera
i'm wondering
if you can in the movie what gnar is
it's probably just them like ranking
things like how can we just like like
well that's a cool trick another trick
he did was really cool too but how can
we tell which trick is better it's only
if only we had a system whoever claims
it louder bro
i can't i can't get over that that
rating system oh my gosh that's so weird
yeah
dude
shane
has a bunch of credits on imdb dude
oh wait he's dead
yeah he died 2009 at the age of 39
probably doing something gnarly how did
he die in 2009 and directly in 2011. i
don't know
he starred in it he started it he didn't
my question
mcconkey die
he might not have claimed died in a ski
base accident in italy
dude that was pretty gnarly he lost his
life
oh dude
ski so hard he died left behind a wife
and a five-year-old daughter oh man
that's sad i feel bad for even joking
wait how did it happen how did he die
what happened jake tell us the story
there's so many ways to die if you're
not in this podcast
let's find out what happened here here
here we go well it wasn't gaffney it was
the other guy uh right yeah mcconkey his
his monkey his gnarly bro
[Music]
dang or what's he normally happened here
how old are these guys
they're
in there they're probably gonna hear
this podcast now 40s or 50s
shane mcconkey died in a ski base jump
on uh sas pardoy a mountain in the
stellar group of the italian dolomites
one of his skis failed to release
sending him into a spin
after he corrected the problem it was
too late to deploy his parachute well
it's a base jump it's a bass jump we're
gonna just ski off a cliff
oh that's gnarly
why didn't he
pull his shoot
he just kind of spin he was in a spin
oh
yeah dang dude i'm pretty sure like
parachutes need like
they need to catch the wind to open so
he's got his own film called mcconkey
2013 documentary film about extreme
skier shane mcconkey
uh wow i wonder what the other what what
are the gaffney boys up to are they dude
rob gaffney the guy who's uh the gnar is
named after uh apparently like
went to med school and psychiatry and
was uh he served as the chief resident
at the use at uc davis
what hey man good for him are you sure
this is the same resident in in tahoe
city yeah are you sure this is the same
guy no i'm not sure i'm not just looking
further i just decided to to read
something very briefly on the internet
and portray it as fact
[Laughter]
like all podcasts yes exactly
uh yeah no it's this is this is the same
way yeah rob gaffney md author and ski
icon
no way an eclectic fellow dude you could
go to his office
look at this let's go
he's got an office in tahoe
right on the water bro
i mean dude an office in tahoe that's
like
that
all right we only got one more to find
out what where are they now here we go
scott gaffney
i think he shows up to the hospital goes
i'm the best doctor here
always in the surgery room
just
naked in the surgery room farting going
i started
hey mom
all right can we get that guy out of
here he's just we let him do his thing
scott goes down to the cafeteria skips
to the front of the line
active uh
as a skier and uh as a film director
he directed the movie mcconkie
that's super wholesome though like he
made a movie about his friend right
that's awesome
um and he's got uh he's got an instagram
profile let's see what's going on here
let's follow him can we comment on this
post
i'm on the corridor account should i
follow him yeah
come on this makes it real
followed
oh my god he did it
we now follow the nar the grand nard
oh my god
oh man
wow this is that's been quite a journey
i did not know this was gonna happen but
hey here's a picture of him jumping off
of a mountain on skis naked comment on
it oh there it is
just
say nine out of ten gnarly
say that
only nine out of ten though nine out of
ten
gnarly
oh dude are we trolling we're shooting
number four
for dinar father
all right here we go he he is officially
the nar father dude all right so um
scott and uh brother rob if you guys are
hearing this um thanks for you know the
gnar um that's all i got to say
thanks for claiming your parts it's been
a journey it's been a journey
we all learned i did not know we were
going to end up there but here we are
here we are
oh my god stop
all right play us out jake i could stop
i'm not gonna lie this is no this is
getting pretty heavy on my my neck
oh dude you got
for the sound effect here ready
oh that wasn't even that was just wet
dude doing that gnar it's humid in there
dude
that's why you wear a shirt underneath
this to separate the silicone from your
skin
doing that gnar
one of my favorite beers is called nar
thanks for listening to the podcast
everybody we enjoyed hanging out with
you for another episode double ipa
another week
thanks for watching thanks for listening
yeah a lot of people listen do you think
more people listen than
oh are we ready